dallas caico going to the mount with one
mission keep the ball down throw ground
balls on for his 14th start his era a
touch over four
to shortstop tim anderson
and abreu rescues another one he has
been rangy at first base tim didn't
really get a good grip on it that's why
he almost threw wide of the bag jose
with a good stretch but that took a
really unusual hop
randy or rosarina who hit the ball hard
three times last night he doubled he
homered he lined down he struck out
change up strike three good start for
dallas kykel
rose arena lost his helmet in the
process
yeah that's because he had so much
snap at the finish of that swing that it
yanked his head
diaz he's a very patient hitter last
year and still is
strike three cutter aced him
lower inside corner on a cutter he's got
two strikeouts it will be the flame
throwing young lefty shane mcclanahan
making his ninth start of the season the
record at two and one the era just over
four and a half and 33 in two thirds
innings and as you can see flame
throwing that average heater at 97.2
into the air and right field that's
margot to make the catch
man left and second lefty lefty brian
goodwin
this into left field is the second hit
of the inning so lefty lefty brian
goodwin comes through
and two on with two out for danny
mendick
lifted into center
that's kiermeier making the catch
so two hits no runs rosarina struck out
on three pitches in the first inning and
is in danger of doing so here
called him out strike three
way off the inside
thank you
james hoy is getting an earful right now
from a rosarina tim anderson's second
time up
one for one
tim little knuckle shot to first base
he's gonna win this race tim easily
coasts in there
for a single if andrew vaughn had seen
mighty ducks he would know that's a
knuckle puck mcclanahan was a spectator
he just looks at it and i'm not sure
what he was thinking about but as soon
as this ball is hit to the right side
you have to sprint
two and one now to abrayu
[Applause]
runner at third with two outs
ground ball right side
[Applause]
out of the zone
gets them on the ground ball brasso to
diaz now mike brasso
that's a liner in the left that's going
to be a base hit a couple of hops his
mom makes the pick up
diaz stops at second
and so for the first time tonight the
rays have two men aboard at the same
time
two out for wendell 3-1
to left field andrew vaughn squeezes out
number three dallas maneuvers through
trouble and will go bottom four annie
mendick batting for the second time with
two on and two out two and
one on his way home a rosarian's throw
to the plate gets through the wickets of
mejia
here comes the second
save once again
danny mendick comes through and then
gets some pretty decent base running but
if mejia handles the throw
they're going to cut down blonde at the
plate
this one got to home plate well
before andrew vaughn but it's skidded
under mejia
sox have the lead at two to nothing
it's angle grondal and abreu coming up
gotta look for a little bit more now
you're going through the heart of the
adam watts order
in the air to left field this is crushed
and bringing him home three nothing
adamant hit it awfully hard in the third
inning when he took it to right field
this time he got out in front pulled it
out of the
ballpark and the sox enjoy a three-run
lead
or angle that's his third and that's his
third run batted in and our ford home
run replay
he got just about all of this he's very
strong
and we get that kind of extension and
you catch the ball out front
it travels a while
adam engel he was sitting there waiting
and he delivers an explosive
high-towering blast
and he made that left-hander pay
austin meadows 33 home runs a
career-high 2019 two years ago
2-2
broken bat pop-up dallas and all of his
cy young
and gold glove glory makes the catch for
round number one what's your best bet to
get this double play from yani diaz best
bet is a cutter inside
to third garcia nice pick medic the turn
[Applause]
that's why he asked the questions
i rest your case in any case the innings
over give dallas credit tonight too the
left-handers in this lineup and we
thought tampa bay might deploy more of
them lefties are just one for seven
tonight
against dallas kykel
check swing
and that'll do it strike three
one two three seven dallas leaves just
six outs for this bullpen his walls in
third and two down in the eighth aaron
can make things a whole lot easier
on liam hendricks
if he can leave that man stranded at
third banks
took him out
aaron responded beautifully to the walk
on one out of the night
against leon hendricks
and there's a hot shot base hit
[Music]
diaz will go to second base
and the rays will get the potential
tying run to the plate
a pinch hitter allow hit a home run last
night
two on one
out him out into the attic with 99.
once you establish you're going to throw
that slider
all of a sudden it opens up upstairs
tying run at the plate with wendell
one and two
he went around that strike three yes
completes the deal and the series is on
the line tomorrow
thanks to a shutout from dallas kykel
tonight in seven innings and the bullpen
got the job done